[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen leckeren herzhaften
muss top job und zwar in form eines
kranzes und in der mitte habe ich einen
richtig leckeren frischkäse tipp den
hefezopf könnt ihr im prinzip film so
wie ihr möchtet ich habe ihn jetzt mit
walnüssen zimt und getrockneten feigen
gefüllt und in der creme habe ich
getrocknete tomaten ziegenkäse und
frischkäse können natürlich auch
variieren wenn ihr möchtet
ich sage euch jetzt erstmal die zutaten
für den hefeteig hefeteig verwende ich
einen würfel hefe einen esslöffel honig
150 gramm warmes wasser 100 gramm warme
milch einen teelöffel salz etwas pfeffer
einige hundert gramm olivenöl und 500
kommen
ich mache jetzt zuerst einen vorteig und
nehme jetzt die hefe und löste im wasser
auf ihr könnt jetzt auch nur einen
halben würfel hefe benutzen dann ist
aber die aufgeht seid einfach ein
bisschen länger je weniger hefe ich
nehme umso länger muss ich den teig
natürlich auch am ende aufgehen lassen
also wenn ihr viel zeit habt könnt ihr
die hilfe wirklich auch reduzieren
hier gebe ich jetzt noch den honig dazu
kann alles kurz berühren
jetzt könnt ihr diesen vortrag einfach
abdecken und hier bei raumtemperatur
stehen lassen da braucht es etwa 15
minuten oder er stellt ihn in den warmen
backofen bei 30 bis maximal 35 grad und
wenn ihr dann noch dampf dazu gibt also
die gern stufe macht dann dauert nur
etwa fünf minuten
gewiss die hefe mit und wasser hier rein
die lok schon von ganz alleine rein geht
echt volk schnell und dann kommen jetzt
hier einfach die restlichen zutaten dazu
und ich kann den teig schön geblieben
[Musik]
bei mir ist der hefeteig gibt es noch
ein bisschen zu weich wie ihr seht es
kommt einfach auch immer darauf an was
wenn mail benutzt oder wie groß das
eigelb war gebe es hier einfach noch
einen esslöffel mehl dazu und natürlich
könnt ihr den tag auch mit der hand
verkneten
das ist jetzt immer gern mit der
küchenmaschine weil ich hier auch diese
funktion habe und ich habe natürlich
auch weiter hinterfragt
jetzt ist daher wird und zu einer kugel
formen
ich hätte einfach die hände mit ein
bisschen olivenöl und dann freue mich
ihn zu einer kugel jetzt lege ich die
kugel hier in die schlüssel zurück
bestreicht sie noch mal mit etwas öl
damit sie nicht austrocknen und kann
sich abgedeckt entweder eine stunde bei
raumtemperatur aufgehen lassen
oder ich werde den teig jetzt einfach in
den dampfgarer wiedergeben oder in den
warmen backofen bei etwa 35 grad und
dann für etwa eine halbe stunde aufgehen
lassen
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist aufgegangen jetzt wird
er gefüllt und zwar habe ich hier für
getrocknete feigen walnüsse etwas zimt
und olivenöl
ich nehme es zuerst die getrockneten
feigen und die werde ich jetzt einfach
fein hacken
christine jetzt schön fein und die
walnüsse die werde ich jetzt kurz einmal
am besten direkt mit dem zimt jetzt wer
mich einfach die wahl müsse mit dem zimt
und mit den feigen in einer schüssel
ich freue mich hier kurzum hole meine
silikon matte zum ausrollen und dann mit
der zucht von getötet jetzt ist der
hefeteig fertig und ich kann ihm
ausrollen einfach auch ein bisschen mehr
und großes rechteck das richtig ist
jetzt 50 mal 40 cm groß und hier kommt
jetzt das öl drauf
[Musik]
und dann kommen da jetzt die walnüsse
und die feigen drauf wir füllen der
jetzt praktisch wieder in lostopf und
das zimtpulver das passt perfekt dazu
[Musik]
doch mit dem ja ein bisschen drücken und
dank aufrollen
und damit werde ich jetzt eine pizza
blechschmidt etwas markttrends bleibt
kurz zur seite und werde jetzt die zöpfe
aufschneiden auf einer auf einem
schneidebrett natürlich einfach hier in
der mitte und jetzt wird geflochten und
ich mache immer erst mal bis zur mitte
damit nicht auseinanderfällt und jetzt
um den anderen strang immer wieder
zwiebeln und dann umdrehen und die
andere hälfte schreiben
[Musik]
so wie ich jetzt hier rein und dann
gucke ich immer dass ich die enden noch
mal schön verbinde damit es nicht zu
anderen langenberg gestiftet aussieht
wenn man es denn hier drunter steckt
dann sieht man den anfang nicht mehr
ich fühle mich noch offen feste backform
für die mitte und besprühte jetzt auch
mit back trance prey
damit der teig nicht festklebt und so
las ich den job jetzt nochmal aufgehen
ich stecke noch mal in einem backofen
noch mal eine halbe stunde etwa und
danach wird er erst gebacken und die
zwischenzeit kann ich aber schon mal
nutzen und den leckeren tipp für die
mitte hin zu bereiten
[Musik]
die pflegecreme verwende ich 200 gramm
frischkäse 207 etwas zitronensaft eine
knoblauchzehe 2 getrocknete tomaten und
einen esslöffel von dem tomaten öl einen
teelöffel honig vom salz und pfeffer
thymian krediten käsecreme passt gut
dazu frisch gepflückt richtig lecker und
gewaschen natürlich ich nehme mir zuerst
getrocknet und tomaten
die kommen hier direkt rein mit dem öl
ist immer ganz wichtig wie eine
getrocknete tomaten kaufte ihm klafft
also in öl eingelegt dann könnt ihr das
öl einfach weiter benutzen also nicht
wegschmeißen
dann kommt da die knoblauchzehe rein das
kann ich jetzt mit dem thymian
zerkleinern
[Musik]
man kommt erzählt erzielten käsereien
monat wird diesen tipp echte leben der
liebt ziegenkäse mein papa übrigens auch
dann bröselig sind jetzt hier hinein
einfach ganz grob und kann den mit
zerkleinern
[Musik]
kann ich hier noch den frischkäse
einrühren ich habe noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft dazu und ein bisschen salz
und pfeffer salz gar nicht zuviel
erstmal nur eine prise und dann mit dem
honig abschmecken
[Musik]
was übrigens einfacher wenn jetzt
einfach auf zwei portionen macht dann
ist schon ziemlich viel masse und jetzt
kann ich die creme umfeld und mit dem
hefezopf servieren
kammradt kamerad oder ausprobieren so du
arbeitest nicht meines handys stock nein
weil ich im garten arbeite und draußen
herzhaften jetzt darf probieren
okay ich habe deinen horizont aussagen
also die form die haftet nicht da muss
man natürlich abwarten dass die bisher
teller wieder gekühlt ist zum 1
und dann ich bin ich ehrlich sagen euch
mehr herz man sieht es ihm nicht an
eigentlich bitter süße typ und man sagen
dass keiner aus deswegen nicht so klein
und ich stehe auf dem hocker ok hab mir
mal aber zerstört nicht ganz denn wir
müssen noch fotos war
schmeckt süßlich der japanische
entwickler zu essen weil da sind jetzt
zeigen dann getrocknet und die passen
halt perfekt zum ziegenkäse jetzt
zerstört stimmt beiden passen
unterzukriegen bestimmten es gut jetzt
ist ja richtig cool ich muss sagen ich
bin absolut gegen diese wenden ich legte
sascha merk dir mag ich rausnehmen gut
hat er gleich was zum essen und ihr
könnt das rezept gerne nachmachen
stoppt die anderen das rezept findet ihr
auf sallys - blog.de und mache das
rezept gerne nach es ist halt auch ein
echt tolles mitbringseln also wenn man
eingeladen ich komme das projekt
mitnehmen also raus angeschnitten
angelaufen ist dann sieht es echt
richtig hübsch aus kann es wirklich
mitnehmen oder muss es wohl hier kann
ich mir ehrlich nein ich muss also bis
zum nächsten mal
ich musste daraufhin dem krieg